[Music]
hi welcome back to another video on
blender video editing on code techni
toriel's if you're new here don't forget
to subscribe if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more stuff it also helps
support me a lot so I appreciate it
and let's get right into it my name is
Matt and I'll be showing you how to do
timing in your blender videos it speed
up slow down and anything else you might
want to do I haven't covered this yet
it's a little different there's a couple
ways to get to your video editing you
can click up here and go to video
editing and get to a tab that way or you
can also go to file new video editing
and it kind of gives you a video editing
layout set up or it doesn't have as many
options so you have your files over here
you've got your preview of what you're
looking at the salt defaults and you've
got your scene properties over here
you've got your sequencer right here and
some stuff about whatever you have
selected and your sequencer over here so
we're not actually going to use this
section over here for the files because
I'm just gonna drag it in from my file
folder which works just as well so you
can do either whenever comfortable with
so I'm gonna drag in this ap misfortune
it's a league of legends match where I
just played ap and recorded nothing too
special and drag this out and let's just
say okay this is a real long video it's
like 20 minutes or something and let's
just say I want to grab a section middle
and speed it up as an example or you
know just we don't want yeah I mean we
couldn't speed up the whole video but
also you could just speed up certain
clips of it because you don't
necessarily want speed up an entire
video too often unless you're doing it
in the YouTube controls or something
like that you know so what we're gonna
do here is we're going to find a little
section or there's some action hopefully
where I get skills or something I know
a game I remember I did pretty well so
let's go to the lake game and take a
look at that I don't think we ended up
winning but I did okay for ap misfortune
I also complained a lot about maybe
misfortune because I think it's terrible
but I wanted to try it anyway here it is
there's a couple kills there so let's
back it up
I'll go right here or it was dead and we
want to take a chunk of this so there
are a couple different ways to do this
I'm going to show you both of them that
I know and and then you can choose to
apply whatever you think is best for you
so we're just I'm gonna show you the
hard cut method first and then I'm also
going to show you the soft cut method
and that's just what I'm calling them I
don't know if it's actually what they're
called the soft cut way I'll show you
later you can do to both hard cuts and
soft cuts and it works this first one
I'm going to show you only works with
hard cuts and if you don't know what
hard cuts means explain it a couple
videos ago I don't remember exactly
where but basically it means with a soft
cut you cut your video and then you can
still but you can still drag the length
so if I lose these up I can still drag
the length and restore the part I cut so
that's a soft cut now a hard cut let me
undo a few times before I cut but you do
a soft cut with just the K hotkey you do
a hard cut with shift K and with a hard
cut move these up it does not allow you
to restore video that you previously cut
as you can see it's grayed out so with a
hard cut you have like permanent ends on
your little clip and you can't modify
those in the soft cut you can't so let's
go up to about right here
and what into here was another hard cut
so we're just gonna shift k and we have
our card cut now I'm just gonna get this
out of the way I'm only gonna be working
with this section so I'm gonna change
the end to where I am now and I'm gonna
change the beginning to where this
starts and I'm gonna edit that before I
record or before I render so it's at
this frame or to start it here that
gives us our render section of this part
we're working on so first we're gonna
mess with the video I'm gonna select the
video I'm gonna go to add effects trip
speed control and I'm just cool down a
little bit to effect strip and you'll
see by default it stretch input to do
strip length so that's what we're gonna
use on this first one that's the example
since then this can only be done on the
hard cuts if you try to do this on a
soft cut it also when you're stretching
the input length it also changes what
video the length of the video and stuff
and it just doesn't work right
in my experience maybe I was missing
something but as far as I know this only
works properly with hard cuts so with
this way you can just drag it to
wherever and it'll speed it up
accordingly to play the whole clip this
doesn't work on the video only the speed
so I'm just gonna grab the end here of
your video and let's say we just want it
I don't know triple time four times
we'll do it four times so first I'm
gonna change this up here to a Python
console just so I can do some math I
don't take this giant and while this
number of its length see ten five seven
three and I'm gonna divide it by four
and I'll get this number which is a
little awkward but it rounds down to 26
43 so I'm gonna change the length to
2643 and you can do that by selecting
your video and you can manually drag it
or you can just type it in under where
is it time I think yeah the duration
here to the new duration of 2643 and
there we go so that is approximately a
quarter of the length and it should play
the whole thing if it's in for time
speed because that's how the math works
out and you want to do the same with the
volume except with the volume you just
have to adjust the pitch I don't know if
there's another way of doing this pitch
makes it sounds like sound like
chipmunks if you're speeding it up
basically you just want to go four times
faster adjusted to the same length and
now we got our new endpoint to render
this piece right here at wherever we are
so I'm going to copy that so this here
is the current location your cursors at
and this is starting endpoints case I
glazed over that earlier so now we have
a start and end point for our four times
render more time speed render let's set
up our render properties
let's bring the quality down 25% so it
renders quickly and we will change our
output to our rendered folder I don't
want to go into my documents and I don't
want a bunch pngs on ffmpeg video and
under encoding I want to make sure I get
the audio to AAC and that should take
care of all this stuff we need to render
properly let's go ahead and render
animation with ctrl f12 or you can go up
here and it should fly through it and
get our thing we'll watch it afterwards
okay there we go it looks like it
finished we'll close out of this will go
into our folder word rendered which is
render here find it it was these on
frames nine four two six two nine six
eight nine yeah that's the one and let's
just play
okay I'm just perfect so yeah that was
four times speed up and as you can see I
was all chipmunk but the timing seemed
to a-line
uh yeah and of course it was blurry
because I put it at 25% if I did a final
render at a hundred percent it would
look a lot better but it would take a
lot longer so that was just an example
that's the example of how to do it with
this stretch to input length and that
one is just more modular if you don't
care about sound it's a way easier
because you can just be like I want this
section to be this long and that's that
and it'll fly through it at that speed
so that's kind of nice so let's move on
to a different section I'll show you
something else let me go down here just
different section of the video I don't
know what this is and I'm going to show
you the soft cut way so I'm just going
to do a K right here I'm also going to
change the starting point to this here
and let's go I'm not going to go as long
as last time is this just a random
section where I'm dead it is back that's
terrible and I'm gonna put the second
point around here so let's say you want
to do the same thing here but you want
to manually type in the numbers rather
than grab the edges another soft cut so
we're gonna I'm gonna grab this clip
move it up here so what's happening
there
crap move don't seem to move that one oh
it's because I have the end of it
clicked it's highlighted so grab move
grab move on the Y so you hit G and then
press Y it locks it to the Y access axis
so you don't accidentally drag it left
and right so that's a cool trick
removing things up and down so we want
to take these these are now soft cut so
if we will do the same thing back strip
you can do shift eight it add that or
you can click over here
FEX trip and speed control but now since
it's a soft cut if you try to use the
stretch input to to let strip length it
also adjusts what of this strip is
showing and it doesn't I don't know it
doesn't seem to work as you would think
and doesn't like this with the old
method will create a slowdown but now
I'm just extending the video and keeping
it at the same speed and it's just like
alright so that didn't work so what you
have to do instead can you get out of
this here control Z to go back okay so
what you have to do instead is you still
go to your speed control go to the
properties over here uncheck this and
then use as speed you basically get a
variable you get a speed factor and a
multiply speed at zero it's nothing
because it's zero times one so you
basically are stuck on the same frame is
what should happen yeah as you can see
here it's just the same frame the entire
time because it's not moving it looks
like there might be well that's the old
video so you can freeze frame it by
doing this to a single frame so that's
kind of a cool trick but we don't want
to have a freeze frame and you want to
actually do a speed control you want a
speed factor these are basically
multiplied together so if you want 4
times speed you do 1 as the speed factor
4 times the multiply speed and there
that's fed up now it doesn't adjust the
length for you that's something you have
to do so you basically just punch these
numbers and reduce it down to well that
rounds to 178 so we'll make it 178 so go
to the strip length here under time
duration 178 and we'll do the same thing
with this audio will just pitch it to 4
times and we'll read it will make the
length the same you can hold control
when you're when you've grabbed an end
and it'll snap to other points and then
we can adjust the little end to where
the curve
is now and we should be able to render
that at four X I want to move this one
up to 50 percent because it's way
shorter and I think everything else is
still set from the previous it looks
like we got our speed ups in there pitch
shifted that's that one by four speed
then we'll just render one times four
yeah so four times speed and we use the
same pitch shift if there's another way
to do the audio I'd like to know because
there's got to be another way other than
pitch shifting I don't know a devil I
don't know if blender allows it you'd
probably do it with audacity or
something better but yeah the chipmunk
effect or the slow rule it's the only
way you seem to be adjust the audio so
you might have to do that another
program if you want something else
special okay let's see what we got here
a render finish that was this one here I
you see we got that four times speed-up
was a very quick video that time but in
effect we did just the same so yeah
that's how you can speed up sections of
your video I hope you enjoyed this video
on how to do the speed controls in
blender for your videos so I hope this
helped I think the like if it did leave
me comments below and I'll catch you
guys in the next video take it easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]